[Music]
did you guys see that
super mega viral very sad video of the
Asian man who's a canned collector being
abused okay I got a lot of people send
it to me that are you gotta talk about
it and I was like I sad to watch the
video but I know what's happened I don't
know what I read about it I actually me
too every time something sad and it's
going viral and I scroll and then people
are like outraged and I'm like I'm not
watching I'm not watching anything for
this you watch the me6
because I read about it and I was gonna
get tomb angry because there's six of us
so me six so that I was gonna get angry
and then I didn't want to be that angry
because I had to relax so did you watch
the Gypsy music videos to watch yes
music videos just make my heart it's all
happy can you introduce me some of your
favorite gypsy tracks yeah we'll send me
some cuz he's giving me such joy when
you need to relax after watching it okay
no it's gonna make you mad it's gonna
really piss you off
yeah so warning it's gonna piss you the
[ __ ] yeah god I'm gonna cry
okay here we go
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
the security guys telling him to leave
the second part of the video was
released days after the first part went
viral and people were thinking that that
was SS because this took place in San
Francisco and they were thinking that
this was SFPD but it wasn't it was a
security security company that were
there and so they're being investigated
I thought you said use Gatsby well he
did get assaulted he did hit and get hit
on the with the broom do you know the
back story or anything like that there's
no back story well this guy he is a 70
year old man yes he's originally from
the Guangdong Province of China he has
lived in San Francisco for six years he
supports himself by collecting campaign
dollars a lot of cash yeah so he
supports himself and his wife by
collecting cans his wife works in home
health care and he was saying because
afterwards there was some other person
in the community that spoke to him
yeah and so this other guy was being
interviewed and he was saying that the
victim is saying that the people in the
neighborhood treated him very very very
kindly and they always give him cans and
that's the reason why he has so many
Kansas because everyone's always out
there to try to help him yeah the people
that the group of people that attacked
him do not represent everyone in that
neighborhood and he wants to make that
very clear that what a great statement
yeah from a guy that did that was a
victim he's still watching out for that
community yeah
and so he did say that he got assaulted
and that it happened last week and that
he was hit on the head with the stick
and robbed of his cans so was it another
homeless guy or something or some those
guys are just [ __ ] I don't know if
they're homeless i they may have even
just thrown that [ __ ] away as far as I
know they have made an arrest and it's a
20 year old named Wayne he was booked on
charges of robbery
elder abuse and probation what about
hate crime right probation violation for
prior robbery convenience
conviction and a hate crime enhancement
okay they said cuz the guy that was
hitting him with a stick that guy that
guy was the aggressor he was the bully
and everyone else was just kind of
watching and enjoying the show right
which is cool it's like like we're the
most annoying parts and we're like I
don't gonna help him I hate agents right
yes so this is the 20 year old that got
arrested
is he the guy that was recording it um I
I know that he wasn't when they
assaulted him yeah did he get charged
for assault oh I see yeah see so that's
all that's kind of agent - okay
yeah hate myself your passport Cambodian
guy I was some like trying to get some
information cuz I was like yeah let's
start let's let's send this dude some
money right but then after SFPD post on
Instagram that they said they found the
old Asian dude he made a statement he
said he doesn't want he wants to cry
yeah that's why we she's a prideful man
so he's like nope I get it but that's
what I'm saying he those are the people
who really need it but there's a lot of
people that are trying to find money and
funding and then or the creating these
accounts but they're fakes so much gonna
everybody but here's the thing like
everybody you know whenever something
happens like this I get hit up a lot too
like yo Tim make a video about this or
something or like address it and I felt
like I don't I don't like making videos
about something unless I have something
different to say
cuz I feel like everybody's kind of
saying hey you know like this is [ __ ]
up on the gap we know it's [ __ ] up
right but what I did think was [ __ ] up
with [ __ ] which almost made me make a
video about it was I hate when when
something like this comes out and then
everybody automatically hates the other
yeah both of them I still make dumbass
comments like there's there's stupid
people from every race right because of
that that's why San Francisco they
created this whole thing called a
community unity and healing event which
took place today
that's awesome and that whole the whole
point of the event is to bring together
like the Asian community and the black
community so there won't be any like
rivalry or whatever I think it's because
[ __ ] of every race they go they get
line and then they're difficult to
control even from the people of that
group so for example control [ __ ]
right I mean like they are the bullies
out of the group so like for example
like let's say like there is I don't
know like a neo-nazi dude or whatever he
doesn't represent white people but he's
the one that's going out and being an
aggressor and a bully to minorities or
whatever and then people get that idea
of oh all why people are like this
because this is my negative interaction
in this case they look like a bunch of
thugs they look like they don't look
like respectable normal right
quote-unquote black folks in the
community they look like some bunch of
dudes that are just chillin and if I can
not doing [ __ ] with their lives and they
they're bored so they got to [ __ ] around
with the dude and so to me it's like
they might be the bullies of their
community where it's difficult for
people to keep them in line yeah it's
just like it's it's it's so stupid like
when i retweeted it and like okay so the
two most annoying comments one was like
the first one was like would y'all be
this upset if this happened to an old
black dude like of course he wouldn't I
know that was one of the first questions
I saw like and when you don't fight for
black people but you'll fight for Asian
that's what the media does to us though
cuz we all now think like okay if this
was a black person who are somehow the
lowest on the totem pole is what they
[ __ ] think like would you really care
about it it's like of course I what the
[ __ ] are you talking about any old
person right you know yeah and the
second of my comment was when dudes
would try to like reply to me and be
like oh man you know yeah that's why
black doozer but I'm like come on bro
this isn't the the space for that you
feel me it's one guy if you're black and
a lesbian and a woman they go you're the
lowest lowest lowest on the totem pole
like [ __ ] like this is [ __ ] racism
and sexism
yeah and bigotry like that's what this
stuff is like categorizing people and
assuming that assuming that there's that
low or whatever it's so [ __ ] up it's
only good for comedy not for real life I
love that [ __ ] cuz I mean you know it's
kind of this is what I like okay
primitive humans right like primitive
thinking humans who aren't like that
deep or they they they go based off of
reaction
and super easy shortcut thinking right
so it is human nature to go oh this
tribe this group this whole entire they
are like this we're going to create
categories you create mental shortcuts
and people live off of these mental
shortcuts so someone that might not be
able to be aware of these mental
shortcuts that they build they'll go
black people danger I watched it on news
right there I saw this stereotype so
there yeah that's every one of them and
so they're using this shortcut thinking
and and when that's when they have that
confirmation bias they see it again and
they go see I knew it
black people dangerous look at this
video so that's the kind of [ __ ] that
people have to do work to change but the
media army is [ __ ] up man cuz it
perpetuates there's a vital shift so
yeah to get the clicks I bet you though
don't keep doing some crazy [ __ ] that
divides Asians and blacks and whites and
everybody even [ __ ] more one thing I
do like is this Asian man's hustle yeah
that's him coming here for six years and
he goes I'm not above any job and he's
collecting all these cans and it looks
like he might even have like 50 bucks to
a hundred bucks worth of aluminum hmm
and if you can recycle everyday that's
like three g's that he's making just
from collecting cans a couple of you
were like oh they hit me up but they're
like yeah this guy clicks cans in my
neighborhood yeah is it every day and
everyone's gonna give him cans because
they're at home you know that one though
I wonder if he battles with the other
kin guys maybe that's maybe that's what
we because there's a there's a couple
out there that that collects cans I've
seen them saying this is a monitor part
guy yeah you know I'm talking about the
guy with the hat and he has I like stick
neither here there collects cancer he
sells it is Jaden amulets I would love
to over talk about community [ __ ] but
this is actual community ship like we're
somebody in their community is doing a
thing and they all give them their thing
you know saying like that's what that is
yeah it's in it and that's like instead
of like I don't know sometimes they do
this [ __ ] with like hey we're doing
outreach to make sure that everyone
knows that racism not cool but I'm like
you're I've not seen racism in this area
I'm seeing people in this area giving
this man cans
yeah no reason they could throw them
away they could [ __ ] chuck them in a
recycler they don't need to
care but they do like I don't see racism
I see two or three [ __ ] and then a
couple of [ __ ] [ __ ] it up but
they don't [ __ ] it up for the rest of
them like I don't look at those guys and
go like that's how black people are two
Asian people I guess yeah stupid if this
guy felt threatened constantly in the
black community he wouldn't be even be
there but obviously he's there cuz like
you said they give him the cans they're
nice and in these [ __ ] heads come out
and then they harass his ass it could
happen to any community and then just to
clear up the guy that got arrested was
the one filming so he's the filming guy
cuz the guy that was hitting him with
the stick he looked like a like a bigger
dude he was darker yeah well if they got
that guy they're gonna get the stick guy
oh that's why I say good cuz but you
know that guy is the talker guy the
sticker how good is the police work
though in the community work is really
the rumor spread people can catch the
right person you know so you know
there's people in that community they're
like I know who the [ __ ] did that they
caught the one that was that never even
showed his face yeah yeah [ __ ] had
his Instagram probably you know is
posted to a story that's probably what
kind of sentence do you think like
months was bad well he did violate
probation and on top of that he had a
lot of hate crime well like for somebody
who's doing this for the first time is
it like a good enough warning shot with
like yo I shouldn't do this [ __ ] they
just sent him to a jail in China was
fully as people with coronavirus oh yeah
that's double to Ted that was double
double that's a good punishment to like
yo you have coronavirus and they do that
for like six weeks Oh [ __ ] that's
good tree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you